[Musik]
stimmt
wenn du geld in der kasse ist
doch am liebsten ohne
[Musik]
ist das schlecht formuliert so schlecht
formuliert denn chemiefrei pony das ist
es
den blick alles ist schön das ist
[Musik]
sie sei das kokosöl und naturseifen
alles chemische
verbinden
weißt du nicht ja ich weiß was du meinst
du hast aber ohne ohne sehen gab sich
nicht darling alles fest hinter mir das
ist
[Musik]
selbst die natur kräuter zahnpasta ohne
friede ist chemie alles besteht das
molekül es gibt keine und chemischen
verbindungen auf dieser welt ist seine
sache wie oh ich mag es aber lieber ohne
chemie denn so was gibt es nicht
freunde der sonne jetzt mal ganz im
ernst warum ist alles gute und gesunde
bio und natürlich und alles giftige
chemie alles ist chemie und die natur
ist die beste chemikerin elfer wenn er
das genauso sieht dann teile dieses
video und kennt ihr nicht aus sollte die
lieber auf chemie verzichten wenn ja
schreibt es in die kommentare
wir sehen uns nächste woche bis dahin
bleibt sicher